[Music]
nearly 100% of Iceland's power grid is
renewable and derived from carbon free
sources they also produce a surplus of
energy making it appealing to the nassin
digital economy there's a lot of zero
carbon energy around and this is
something that Bitcoin miners have been
looking
for mining for Bitcoin is very energy
intensive so miners have been around the
world looking for the cheapest and
lowest cost power and the cleanest
energy sources to reduce their carbon
footprint and to reduce their energy
cost so Iceland is a natural
draw we're very close
Okay how long is the eruption going to
last for it with you there's quite a lot
of energy in the ground here that's
that's for
[Music]
sure
this is the heart of Iceland these
eruptions these volcanoes draws power
from something called geothermal energy
geothermal energy originates from this
heat the heat produces Steam and
turbines capture the Steam and power the
country Bitcoin mining is a bit of a
misnomer there's nothing happening with
respect to mining there are no picks and
a is it's simply a data center that's
producing digital assets generating
digital assets takes a certain amount of
energy and it's been very important for
us as a company Mission to draw from
renewable sources of
power 99% of our entire fleet happens to
be carbon- free thanks to some of these
sources of energy like volcanic
[Music]
energy
just under 3,300 machines has this is
100% carbon free data center what we do
here is we mine on energy created out of
water and volcanoes we're
environmentalists were actually very
careful to maximize shareholder returns
while doing it in a socially conscious
way
but not all environmentalists are on
board with this concept many are
concerned at the sheer scale of power
consumption of these data centers and
worry that their endless energy needs
will never be satiated potentially
leading to ecological
disaster at the moment all homes in
Iceland are using less energy than
Bitcoin mining so it's obvious that
Bitcoin is a a huge sector in Iceland
and if we need to build more power
projects we are cutting into ecosystems
geology unique geology and inviting
projects like uh Bitcoin we would need
to uh build more power plants it's hard
to say that we need to build more power
plants when we still have all this
Surplus energy that can be used on
Bitcoin
[Music]
mining in terms of building power plants
I don't have the political influence to
make that happen nor do we want to we're
simply guests here and we're just using
and buying power that is in excess while
there are some disputed plans for more
power plants in Iceland none of them are
being built to power data centers in
fact they are explicitly geared to
service a far more damaging
industry aluminum smelting is consuming
the vast majority of energy in Iceland
it it tends to have have more negative
environmental impact compared to uh
Bitcoin mining the air pollution the
water pollution coming out of the
industry lens verin is Iceland's biggest
power supplier 85% of their demand or or
customers are industrial users or big
Power users like aluminum smelters and
this publicly owned power company has
said they're not going to build more
power plants to serve Bitcoin miners and
L richon sees them as temporary or
short-term contracts that can easily
move in and out but they do want to draw
in more industrial users like aluminum
smelters and so long as power companies
service these larger polluting
Industries there will likely always be
digital stakeholders ready and willing
to buy up any spare energy that comes
their
way and this has to do with the very
nature of power production itself and
the niche market that any sustainably
focused Bitcoin minor relies on to
operate almost all of the energy that is
being used for mining in Iceland today
is is what is called non-g guaranteed
power which is basically a byproduct of
any power production power generators
they have excess energy that energy
would have gone to waste gone into The
Ether but Bitcoin miners are in a unique
position to buy the energy that would
have otherwise been wasted unlike a
factory or an aluminum smelter that has
to be online all the time with an even
rate of electricity usage Bitcoin miners
can throttle back really quickly the
aluminium smelters do not want to buy
this power green houses do not want to
buy this power and households do not
want to buy this power and why do I say
that is because of this curtailment
clause which means that we can get an
email at any given point or a phone call
basically saying we have to shut you
down by so much or completely shut you
down for so
long so this ability to sell non-g
guaranteed power is creating a new
market opportunity in Iceland because
companies can sell the excess Supply
that it has without having to like build
new generation immediately because this
is power that would have gone to waste
anyway or
unused we're the buyers of Last Resort
when it comes to energy buying we're
basically buying the the trash that no
one wants we're buying the energy that
no one is using and that energy is being
monetized on behalf of the country
that's selling it to
[Music]
us